[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
niedrige Sirin in allen einen schönen
guten Abend ja Christian die
Viertelfinalpartien der Frauenfußball WM
stehen an dazu noch Basketball bei mir
später guten Abend los legen wir gleich
mit einem Fall der die Politik alarmiert
Putins Agenten nach dem Spionagefall bei
der Bundeswehr spricht die
Innenministerin von einer verschärften
Sicherheitslage
die asbestfalle die IGI Bau warnt vor
einer Krankheitswelle bei der
energetischen Sanierung von Millionen
Wohnhäusern in Deutschland
und Inferno im Paradies bei schweren
Buschbränden auf einer Hawaii Insel
kommen mindestens 36 Menschen ums Leben
[Musik]
seitdem Ukraine Krieg warnt der
Verfassungsschutz vor der Gefahr
russischer Spionage in Deutschland jetzt
nach der Festnahme eines
bundeswehroffiziers und mutmaßlichen
Rüssel anspitzels sieht Innenministerin
Caesar eine andere Dimension der
Bedrohung Verteidigungsminister
Pistorius kündigt an die militärische
Spionageabwehr zu stärken mattes
Feldhoff mit mehr Details
hinter diesen rustikalen Mauern in
Koblenz sitzt die zentrale Behörde für
alle bundeswehrprojekte vom Kampf
Stiefel bis zum Kampfhubschrauber das
ausrüstungsamt der Bundeswehr ist ein
Ort voller militärischer Geheimnisse
hier arbeitete der mutmaßliche Spion
Thomas H Hauptmann der Bundeswehr soll
im Beschaffungswesen der Truppe tätig
gewesen sein der Tatvorwurf begründet
sich darauf dass mutmaßlich der
Beschuldigte mehrfach Kontakt mit dem
Generalkonsulat der Russischen
Föderation aufgenommen hat hat im Rahmen
dieser Kontaktversuche geheimes Material
übergeben auch in der russischen
Botschaft in Berlin soll Haar gewesen
sein so der Vorwurf der Bundesanwälte
sie unterstellen deshalb dem Offizier
eine Russland Nähe
als auslösendes Moment wird vor allem
Frust über fehlende
Aufstiegsmöglichkeiten im Koblenzer Amt
vermutet so berichten es Insider ein
Mann um die 50 jemand der einen
aufstiegsberuf gewählt hat früher einmal
Unteroffizier war der sich also
angestrengt hat aber offensichtlich
nicht zufrieden ist der Fall erinnert an
den im dezember 2022 enttarnten Spion
beim BND Karsten l hatte offenbar
versucht ein ukrainische militärinfos zu
gelangen
Sicherheitspolitiker sehen die Gefahr
für Deutschland es ist alarmierend
alarmierend weil wir eben viele solcher
Fälle in den letzten Monaten hatten und
es zeigt dass im Bereich der Spionage
und
illige Team Einflussnahme wir eigentlich
in den Zeiten des Kalten Krieges wieder
angekommen sind ha sitzt in
Untersuchungshaft es ist nicht bekannt
ob und wenn ja welche Geheimnisse er
etwa zu waffenprojekten übergab
außermittlungspaktischen Gründen wurden
dazu keine an gaben gemacht
Deutschland hat der Ukraine zwei weitere
Abschussrampen für das Flugabwehrsystem
Patriot geliefert man sei jetzt näher an
einem vollwertigen luftschutzschild
erklärte Präsident selenski und bedankte
sich für die Hilfe tausende leben würden
dadurch gerettet den in den USA gebauten
patriot-systemen soll es schon mehrfach
gelungen sein auch russische Hyperschall
Raketen abzufangen
ja die Luftabwehr ist besonders an den
Orten wichtig die entlang der
ukrainischen Frontlinie unter
Dauerbeschuss stehen eine dieser Städte
ist herrson im Süden des Landes sie
liegt am Fluss den nipro von der anderen
Uferseite aus feuert die russische Armee
wie die Menschen dort in dieser
schwierigen Situation versuchen zu Recht
zu kommen zeigt uns jetzt eine Brühl
jeden Abend so ab 10 geht es los dann
beschießt russische Artillerie das
Wohngebiet in dem mikola zapenco lebt
das Haus seiner Nachbarin wurde gestern
getroffen bei ihm wurde das Dach
beschädigt wir haben keinen richtigen
Bunker wir verstecken uns hinter zwei
Wänden wie man uns gesagt hat nur einige
wenige sind im Zentrum der Stadt
unterwegs vor dem Krieg haben hier mal
300.000 Menschen gewohnt geblieben sind
noch 45.000 so wie Irina mit ihren drei
kleinen Kindern ich habe ihnen
beigebracht was Sie tun müssen wenn es
sehr laut ist wir haben unsere Sachen
parat wenn was ist dann sind wir
zusammen
ich will Ihnen folgendes sagen wenn alle
auswandern wer wird das alles wieder
aufbauen damit unsere Kinder hierher
zurückkommen können
Leben in Hassan das ist ein dauernder
Ausnahmezustand auch für Polina zum
Abschied fällt sie mir spontan um den
Hals
Luftalarm ständige Angriffe mit Raketen
und Artillerie das Leben in Person ist
gefährlich die Russen stehen auf der
anderen Seite des Flusses nur sechs
Kilometer vom Stadtzentrum entfernt
ultra hat die russische Besatzung der
Stadt überlebt zeigt uns Ihr Haus das
nach der Zerstörung des kachowka-damms
bis zum ersten Stock unterwasserstand
immer wieder ist heftiges
Artilleriefeuer zu hören weit weg sagt
eurer
wir waren hier als es am schlimmsten war
kein Beschuss kann so schlimm sein wie
es die Besatzung war ultra will mit
ihrer Familie in Hass und bleiben zurück
in ihr Haus kann sie erst einmal nicht
ja anders als in der Ukraine ist der
Krieg in Russland im Alltag der Menschen
nicht allgegenwärtig zum einen weil es
ihn offiziell nicht gibt und zum anderen
weil man bei jedem kritischen Wort gegen
den kremmelkurs Gefahr läuft verhaftet
zu werden nur ganz wenige trauen sich
offen auszusprechen was sie denken für
begabberichtet
in diesem Hinterhof lebt das Gewissen
von St Petersburg so nennen sie jede
ausziehbar hier die 77-Jährige
Künstlerin erholt sich nur langsam von
einem Schlaganfall und doch kämpft sie
gegen den Krieg gegen die
Teilnahmslosigkeit ihrer Mitmenschen
jelenas neueste Botschaft Russland
bedarf einer Rehabilitierung nach
schwerer Krankheit
wir haben jetzt genau die gleiche
schwere Krankheit wie einst Deutschland
es ist genau dasselbe
immer weiter bewegt sich Russland in
Richtung Diktatur immer stärker werden
die Freiheiten im eigenen Land bekämpft
alles was nicht der Haltung des Regimes
entspricht kann bestraft werden mit
einem westlichen Fernsehteam zu sprechen
auch Vitali will Kapitän werden dass der
ST Petersburger studiert schützt ihn vor
dem Militärdienst einige seiner
Kommilitonen hatten sich freiwillig
gemeldet und sind gefallen
sie sind natürlich Helden ich will in
keiner Weise ihre Arbeit abwerten aber
es ist doch traurig dass die Regierung
dass die Menschen die sich mit Politik
beschäftigen es so weit kommen lassen
aber eigentlich möchte er sich nicht
ständig mit dem Krieg beschäftigen das
mache sein Gehirn nicht mit sagt der
24-Jährige
Jelena kann nicht wegsehen ihre Proteste
alleine auf der Straße Enden jedes Mal
mit einem Polizeieinsatz oft mit einer
Geldstrafe Repressionen Gewalt Angst
wenn der Krieg vorbei ist sagt Jelena
werde es noch lange dauern bis die
russische Gesellschaft geheilt sei
ja und zu den vielfältigen Folgen des
Angriffskrieges senden wir heute teil 1
einer Dokumentation macht Poker an der
Ostsee um 22 Uhr im ZDF oder jetzt schon
in unserer Mediathek
genau 75 Jahre ist sie her die
Geburtsstunde unserer Verfassung zum
Jubiläum fand Bundespräsident Steinmeier
heute deutlicher Worte wir alle müssten
die Demokratie schützen dazu gleich mehr
zuvor erklärt Delia Thomas wie es
eigentlich zum Grundgesetz kam
1948 fordern die westlichen Alliierten
von den Politikern in ihren
Besatzungszonen eine Verfassung zu
erarbeiten einige Ihrer Vorgaben lauten
Demokratie als Staatsform sowie
Föderalismus als geteilte Macht zwischen
Bund und Länder klare Gewaltenteilung
also Trennung zwischen Gesetzgebung
Ausführung und Justiz und garantierte
Menschen und Freiheitsrechte
am 10 August 1948 beginnen Politiker und
Experten auf der Herreninsel im Chiemsee
mit der Arbeit ein großes Ziel die
Fehler der Weimarer Verfassung zu
vermeiden und eine stärkere stabilere
Demokratie zu schaffen deshalb gibt es
strenge Anforderungen für Änderungen an
der neuen Verfassung und
Volksabstimmungen werden als politisches
Instrument zur Ausnahme außerdem können
verfassungsfeindliche Parteien verboten
werden
die Bezeichnung Grundgesetz wurde
gewählt um den provisorischen Charakter
der Verfassung zu betonen das
Grundgesetz wird am 8 mai 1949 vom
Parlamentarischen Rat beschlossen und am
23 mai feierlich verkündet
heute also ein Festakt auf Schloss
Chiemsee und dort mahnende und auch
Schafe Worte von Bundespräsident
Steinmeier zum Zustand der Demokratie
und den Gefahren der sie ausgesetzt ist
Patricia Schäfer war dabei
im historischen Dampfer an einem
historischen Tag der Bundespräsident ist
gekommen um die Demokratie zu feiern am
Chiemsee wo das Grundgesetz seinen
Ursprung hat heute vor 75 Jahren kurz
bevor der Parlamentarische Rat in Bonn
seine Arbeit begann berieten auf der
Herreninsel rund 30 Experten wie eine
neue Verfassung aussehen sollte nach nur
13 Tagen legten die Herren einen Entwurf
vor der in weiten Teilen für das
Grundgesetz übernommen wurde
Bundespräsident Steinmeier nutzte den
Jahrestag bewusst um den Bürgerinnen und
Bürgern ins Gewissen zu reden bei einem
Festakt auf Schloss Herrn Chiemsee
betonte er wie wichtig die wehrhafte
Demokratie ist gerade heute
unser Grundgesetz verträgt harte und
härteste Auseinandersetzung
Verfassungsfeinde jedoch kann eine
Verfassung nicht integrieren und wir
dürfen die Gefahr die von ihnen ausgeht
nicht ignorieren ein deutlicher Hinweis
auf die wachsende Zustimmung zu
Positionen der AFD
kein mündiger Bürger kann sich auf
mildernde Umstände herausreden wenn er
sehendes
politische Kräfte stärkt sie zur verhung
unserer Gesellschaft und zur Aushöhlung
der freiheitlichen Demokratie beitragen
meine Damen und
eine Feier des Grundgesetzes und ein
Aufruf zur Wachsamkeit damit das
Versprechen des nie wieder auch in
Zukunft geht
drei Jahre lang droht zumindest von
Seiten der Piloten kein Streik mehr bei
der Lufthansa denn die Gewerkschaft
Cockpit hat dem Tarifvertrag zugestimmt
bis Ende 2026 gibt es für die Piloten in
mehreren Stufen mindestens 18 Prozent
mehr Geld und garantiert 10 freie Tage
pro Monat
Millionen Häuser in Deutschland müssen
in den nächsten Jahren saniert werden
auch um Energie zu sparen aber in vielen
Altbauten schlummert ein riesiges
Problem es heißt Asbest denn der
krebserregende Stoff wurde erst 1993
verboten davor benutzte man ihn über
Jahrzehnte in mehr als 3000 Produkten
etwa in Dachplatten oder auch in
Spachtelmassen und Fassaden einmal
eingebaut ist Asbest meist ungefährlich
aber beim Ausbau können
gesundheitsschädliche Asbestfasern
freigesetzt werden Stefanie Hein dazu
die Gefahr schwebt in der Luft Fasern
die die Lunge schädigen könnten Asbest
bei der Sanierung von Altbauten das hier
ist eine Demonstration aber genauso soll
eine asbestbelastete Baustelle gesichert
werden Spezial Lüftung Absaugeinrichtung
für das Schleifgerät im genau solchen
dunklen Schichten wurde früher oft
Asbest verwendet und nicht nur da
Abwasserleitungen sind das besserseitig
wandputze deckenputze
Dichtung in Steckdosen in Lichtschaltern
das sind so die Klassiker seit 30 Jahren
ist das bestverwendung in ganz
Deutschland verboten doch so die IG BAU
allein in der Zeit von 1950 bis 89
wurden mehr als 9,4 Millionen große und
kleine Wohnhäuser gebaut oft wohl mit
Asbest jetzt starten vielerort
Sanierungen auch energetische die Gefahr
dabei unwissentlich die krebserregenden
Fasern freizusetzen es ist klar wenn ich
als Heimwerker große größere Arbeiten
mache ja ich reiße die Fliesen raus
machen noch meinen Dach sanieren noch
das Dach dann ist schon ein Risiko
gegeben geringe Dosen reichen sich ja
aus zum Beispiel ein Jahr berufliche
Tätigkeit mit Asbest ist sicher ein
deutliches Risiko an einem bösartigen
Tumor des rippenfells zu erkranken
die Baugewerkschaft fordert mehr
Transparenz um die Gesundheit von Profis
und Heimwerkern zu schützen dafür
brauchen wir einen gebäudepass der
ähnlich wie in Frankreich klar ausweist
was ist in dem Haus verbaut damit
diejenigen die dort bauen auch wissen
dass in diesem die Baustoffe das sind
die und die Asbest war sondern auch
verbaut und das alles wird Geld kosten
deshalb fordert die igibau auch dass der
Staat sich mit einer Art Abwrackprämie
an die nötigen Sanierungen beteiligt
ja was sollte man beachten wenn man beim
Sanieren Asbest findet und welche
Gefahren bestehen antworten auf diese
und andere Fragen haben wir für Sie in
unserer ZDF heute App zusammengestellt
kurz vor den Präsidentschaftswahlen in
Ecuador ist einer der aussichtsreichsten
Kandidaten erschossen worden die Schüsse
auf Fernando via wie sensio vielen nach
einer Wahlkampfveranstaltung der
59-Jährige weiß investigativ Journalist
tätig und stand unter Polizeischutz er
soll mehrfach von Drogenkartellen
bedroht worden sein der amtierende
Präsident Lasso fängt die jetzt für 60
Tage den Ausnahmezustand
herbei ist für viele Urlauber ein
Traumziel jetzt wütend auf der
us-inselgruppe schwere Wald und
Buschbrände mindestens 36 Menschen kamen
ums Leben Hawaii liegt gut fünf
Flugstunden von San Francisco entfernt
mitten im Pazifischen Ozean besonders
betroffen von den Bränden ist Maui die
zweitgrößte Hawaii-Insel und dort der
historische Küstenort große Teile des
beliebten touristenziels wurden zerstört
David sauer berichtet
nachdem die Flammen alles Brennbare
verschlungen haben stehen nur noch die
Grippe von gestern in Lahaina noch
Touristenurlaub machten sind bloß noch
Beton und Asche
da sind doch immer noch tote im Wasser
die treiben da einfach schon seit
gestern ziehen wir hier die Leute aus
dem Meer wir versuchen so viel wie
möglich zu retten aber ich habe langsam
das Gefühl dass wir hier nicht die Hilfe
bekommen die wir brauchen
in ihre Verzweiflung laufen viele auf
die Stege als am Land kein Platz mehr
zum Überleben bleibt
doch auch hier ist es nicht sicher bis
ans Wasser haben sich die Flammen im
Hafen durchgefressen erfassen sogar die
Boote
warum gab es hier so viele Tote das
Tempo der Feuerwalze ließ kaum Zeit zur
Flucht ein Hurricane weit draußen auf
dem Pazifik peitscht Winde von mehr als
130 km/h über Maul dazu extreme
Trockenheit ein rasendes Inferno das sei
alles sehr unüblich sagt ein Pilot
ich fliege hier seit 52 Jahren so was
habe ich hier noch nie gesehen nicht mal
100 Zelda davon
diese Familien sind in Notunterkünften
konnten sich retten sie haben zwar alles
verloren aber sie haben ihr Leben
in erster Linie geht es jetzt darum
Menschenleben zu retten und Leid zu
lindern und dann erst darum Sachschäden
zu begrenzen
Teile von Maui wurden bereits evakuiert
schon mehr als 11.000 Bewohner und
Touristen ausgeflogen doch noch viel
mehr Menschen warten auf ihre
Möglichkeit die Insel zu verlassen und
in Sicherheit zu kommen
wir sind jetzt beim Sport Christin und
für blicken nach dauern anders die
Fußball-Weltmeisterschaft gesehen die
heiße Phase genau die beiden Ruhetage
sind vorbei und zu den Top Favoritinnen
zählt auch das Team aus Japan die Assi
hat einen Treffen morgen im zweiten
Viertelfinale auf die Schwedinnen wohl
wissen dass Japan als einziges Land der
letzten acht schon einmal WM Gold
gewonnen hat 2011
Japan präsentiert sich bei dieser WM
bisher richtig stark drei Siege und kein
Gegentreffer in der Vorrunde dann haben
sie Norwegen im Achtelfinale souverän
gezwungen meine Spielerinnen sind
anpassungsfähig und schalten optimal von
defensiver auf Offensive um dabei sind
sie schnell und haben eine gute
Spielkontrolle eine junge Mannschaft die
auch gegen Schweden im Kollektiv
überzeugen möchte herausragendes
Mittelfeldspielerin Hinata Mia zawa die
bei diesem Turnier schon fünf Mal
getroffen hat wir sind alle fokussiert
zu gewinnen und als starke Einheit
aufzutreten so soll es auch morgen gegen
Schweden sein wir wollen den Sieg ihr
großer Traum lebt 12 Jahre nach dem
letzten Triumph den WM-Titel wieder ins
Land des Lächelns zu holen
ja und die Viertelfinale Runde beginnt
bereits früh 3 Uhr mit der Partie
Spanien gegen die Niederlande zwei
weitere Goldmedaillen für Deutschland
bei den para-weltmeisterschaften im
Radsport in Glasgow Maike Hausberger war
bei den Frauen im Einzelzeit fahren die
schnellste und ihr Teamkollege Matthias
Schindler mit 41 Jahren bei den Männern
Motivation für die deutschen
Basketballer gut zwei Wochen vor Beginn
der Weltmeisterschaft in Asien hat das
Team und Kapitän Dennis Schröder in
Berlin einen schönen Erfolg verbucht
Nerven stark im Testspiel gegen Kanada
der Mannschaftsgeist passt 86 zu 81
gegen das Top-Team aus Kanada Trainer
Gordon Herbert hat heute sein
12-köpfiges Aufgebot nominiert Dennis
Schröder hat sich gestern als Denker und
Lenker eindrucksvoll in Szene gesetzt er
Daniel Theis Moritz und hier beim Kopf
Franz Wagner sind die vier NBA-Profis
der Deutschen nicht dabei sind Oskar da
Silva vom FC Barcelona und Leon Kratzer
der in Paris unter Vertrag steht am
Samstag geht es in Hamburg gegen China
Dennis Schröder bleibt entspannt
mit so einer entzückenden Tochter geht
nicht anders danke
sagen morgen erstmal ein sonniger und
warmer Sommertag und was dann noch kommt
hat gleich Katja hornefahrt um 21:45 Uhr
[Musik]
guten Abend lotte ist ein kurzfrist
sommerhoch denn schon schnell verlässt
es uns ostwärts und räumt das Feld für
tief Arendt das bringt Schauer und
Gewitter mit und Hitze die Hitze kommt
direkt aus Südwesteuropa dort liegen
morgen die Höchsttemperaturen bei 35 bis
45 Grad bei uns werden es um 30 knapp
über 30 Grad heute Nacht sinken die
Werte auf 15 Grad an der Nordsee und bis
7 Grad im Vogtland und es ist häufig
klar nur über den Norden ziehen einige
lockere Wolkenfelder hinweg und das
passiert auch morgen über Tag sonst aber
strahlt die Sonne meist vom blauen
Himmel und erst zum späten Nachmittag
oder Abend werden die Wolken hier im
Westen bei Südwestwind Dichter die
Temperaturen steigen morgen auf 21 Grad
auf Rügen und bis 31° am Oberrhein so
sonnig geht's nicht weiter es kommen
dann Gewitter auf und das können noch
Unwetter sein Gewitter die mit Hagel
Platzregen und sturen verbunden sind es
bleibt aber die ganze Zeit warm und
jetzt schauen wir nach Asien denn über
den Pazifik hat sich der Taifun LAN
entwickelt und der wird wahrscheinlich
bis Dienstag hier die japanische Küste
westlich von Tokio treffen das behalten
wir für Sie im Auge guten Abend